l'an dernier l'indre et loire a
enregistré 300 cas de viol ou agression
sexuelle sur mineur un chiffre
sous-estimé car les victimes souvent
jeunes n'osent pas porter plainte
alors pour les aider à franchir le pas
mais aussi à reconnaître une agression
l'association spécialisée colosse aux
pieds d'argile valeur rencontre c'était
le cas par exemple aujourd'hui à l'école
paul louis courier à amboise romain
delville on a été évoqué tout à l'heure
les violences sexuelles
mais en fait on va juste évoqué ce mot
là et je vais vous expliquer un petit
peu au fil de l'intervention ce que
c'est et comment ça peut exister pour
aborder le sujet de la violence sexuelle
devant des ce2 fabien lefèvre de
l'association colosse aux pieds d'argile
demande aux élèves d'identifier les
parties intimes chez l'être humain
les doigts se lèvent les réponses et les
remarques fusent souvent très
pertinentes personnel et au chai à part
nous et si quelqu'un voulait touche vous
avez que à les personnes qu'on me fait
confiance
puis ce sont les dangers des réseaux
sociaux et des jeux en ligne qui sont
abordés qui a axé sur à internet chez
lui sur une tablette ou un ordinateur
enfin la question du harcèlement moral
et physique continue de délier les
langues
les exemples personnels ne manquent pas
pour soi ou son environnement
des enfants qui qu'ils ont
tapez poussé insulté et tremblay bedo
criminalité harcèlement cyberharcèlement
les sujets sont graves
aborder avec tact et sans tabous face
aux questions des enfants et elle des
trucs le harcèlement est un truc
sexuelle c'est très important adaptés
comme ça
baho contrat courant on se rappellera
c'est ce qui va nous dire les violences
sexuelles
il faut en parler pour les éradiquer et
pour que chaque enfant puisse avoir et
dire mon corps m'appartient